bonjour antoine premier volet donc ce
lundi de ces témoignages inédits de
gilet jaune
quelles sont les suites judiciaires
accordées aux affaires on l'a vu dans
lesquels des gilet jaune ont été
blessées à vie notamment par des armes
de maintien de l'ordre
j'avais déjà interviewé une dalle qui
s'appelle valérie 1 l'année dernière
pour une enquête sur les dangers liés
aux grenades jm2l en manifestation juste
après sa blessure faut savoir qu'un
éclat de cette grenade g m2 elle qui
était vendu comme moins vulnérables que
la guille f 4 qui a depuis été retirée
de la dotation avait traversé le mollet
de l'es7 gilet jaune qu'elle ne faisait
rien de particulier elle était à nantes
avaient manifesté dans la rue
un an plus tard sommes allés chez elle
pour faire le point sur sa situation
et voici un extrait de ce qu'elle nous a
dit on informe que ma plainte
ils peuvent aller elle aura pas de suite
parce que tout simplement ils n'arrivent
pas à identifier le crs ou le gendarme
mobile qui a une qui est à l'origine du
tir de grenade et ensuite on me fait
donc comprendre que de toute façon
j'étais j'avais pas atteint dans cette
manifestation et que je fais partie des
peines perdues
déjà vous hésité à porter plainte parce
que c'est porter plainte contre un
policier
eh ben on m'a fait rentrer à la maison
alors aux douanes comment sa vie at elle
changé
valérie c'est une soignante qui
travaille en maison de retraite
donc depuis sa blessure elle peine
beaucoup à travailler à mobiliser les
personnes âgées
le soir elle est très fatiguée la mal
aux jambes et à peine 40 ans et ne peut
plus faire la plupart des sports qu'elle
faisait auparavant quasiment plus rien
elle a mal tous les jours elle pense
qu'avec l'âge elle devra marcher avec un
déambulateur
on lui a fait comprendre qu'elle aurait
jamais de lorraine ne marcherait plus
jamais normalement mais un an après la
blessure l'en quête a été close et on
n'a pas identifiées donc ce que policier
ou le gendarme qui a lancé la grenade on
lui dit simplement qu'elle est au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment elle a
aucune reconnaissance du dommage subi in
et handicap avec lequel elle devra vivre
désormais
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions on peut suivre et retrouver
évidemment toutes ces enquêtes la
première à retrouver donc sur rt sur le
web rt france point tv à demain antoine
pour le témoignage le deuxième
témoignage de cette semaine merci
beaucoup